hey everybody what's going on welcome to
stream coco
yeah this is a very uh special edition
uh we have two great writers here andre
dubuche and dan cronin and uh
the reason why we decided to do the
stream coco today is because something
happened recently on the show
that um you know every once in a while a
firework explodes in the sky
every once in a while you achieve
whether on purpose or by accident
true greatness
uh that will live on
hundreds of years now it's like when
mozart or beethoven at least another
week at least another week yeah we're
writing this for like two weeks and that
for our show for conan
was a sketch andre wrote
called nut spoon yes that's right nut
spoon everybody and um
you know this has been making waves
across the internet across the world
frankly
and probably out into the cosmos
somewhere it's being beamed out aliens
are probably enjoying nut spoon millions
of years from now
uh and nut spoon uh we're gonna
does that affect our residuals at all
can we get
wga doesn't have a future alien
but we thought actually on a little bit
more of a serious note we thought we
would actually take this opportunity to
talk with these guys uh and you uh a
little bit about the process of comedy
writing and nut spoons in general nuts
spoons and uh the amazing assortment of
wigs that dan cronin wears in the show
which is also
all wigs are hilarious
but before we get started you know
something uh we had one of our favorite
guests on uh very recently carl reiner i
mean comedy legend
uh and karl reiner uh you know when a
guest comes on the show we kind of know
basically what they're going to say we
talk to them ahead of time but carl
reiner actually surprised us and conan
by mentioning something in his interview
that we all thought was absolutely
incredible uh and for those of you who
missed it uh here it is take a look
here's carl reiner
i'm here because i love you oh by the
way before i get to that
i taped it i laughed so hard
you idiots
with a nut spoon oh we did a we did a
sketch
did you see that we did a sketch was it
last week we did a sketch called nut
spoon which this is really saying
something
on the idiocy scale after 24 years of
doing this it was pretty high
by our standards and you saw that it was
the the best nut
it was the best the best sketch i've
seen in a long time oh wow i learned
this very happy
i saved it
i taped it and i play it for friends
you buy the premise yes yes that you
need a spoon to pick up a nut yes yes
i was saying i'm an expert yeah i can go
in there and straighten them out yeah
you pick up a nut with a finger yeah
yeah
no no this is the whole premise of the
sketches you gotta use a spoon and wow i
can't believe a you saw it b you liked
it and c you're showing it to other
people
makes my life 94. there you go carl
reiner
saying how much he loved nuts we that's
got to be a thrill oh it's a thrill i
was telling my wife i can retire now
yeah
i was totally over the moon um yeah and
one of the things he kind of brings up
which is something
which is kind of
amazing which is the premise of nuts
we're actually going to talk seriously
about nut spoon by the way uh which is
the premise which is uh uh that you have
to use a spoon to pick up nuts how did
how did you think of this how did the
i'll tell you exactly i'll tell you
exactly what happened so dan and i were
working on a different sketch we did
these we did these sketches where i
played el chapo sitting in on drums with
the band and the joke there was i kept
tunneling i get tunneling out of the
studio yes so we were in the control
room going over
uh the last changes to that sketch for
that day's show
and there's a snack table in the control
room and it's got like olives and
crackers and cheese and stuff and
there's
a small paper plate with with almonds on
it
and there's a plastic spoon there and
i was like what are you supposed to like
i was like this isn't like i guess i'm
supposed to use the spoon to pick up the
nuts
because it's like a cleanliness thing i
guess you don't want to touch all this
and i was like this is possible i can
only get a couple nuts on this
and then spoon
was like i'm going to write a sketch
about this
that's basically what and actually sarah
asks what's your favorite nut you guys
got favorite nuts probably almonds
cashew all right i like
the smoked almonds do you guys go for
the dry roasted stuff are you more of a
raw i like dry roasted salted almonds
absolutely we should point out this
seems ridiculous but every year about 60
000 people die due to nut germs
so not just nut allergies yeah the nut
spoon is
providing exactly right
gab dog we're in our digital studio this
is we're not in a vault somewhere no
that's not true we're in the back of an
18 wheeler that's true we're abducted
this is just the what is that what's the
thing from stranger things
is the upside down right exactly
uh how do you pick up a nut from a spoon
so yeah and lance you know i mean i
think to lance's point you can't
actually pick up any nuts no it's really
hard right so it's ridiculous uh nikki
in the control room suggested that we
just put the nuts in a bowl right then
it's much easier to get them out with a
spoon
but for some reason we have a little
paper plate and you just kind of nudge
them all over the place and you make a
mess so okay so but let's talk
specifically here so that happens and
you're like oh this is dumb this is a
dumb thing right you know one of the
things i like about nut spoon at the
sketch is the structure of it i think
why it works so well i mean it's almost
seven minutes which is really long
for us and that's a meaty that's a meaty
sketch a lot of nut meat there sorry um
but uh but so let's talk a little bit
about the structure yeah you know um
actually you know what why don't we
watch nut spoon first
and then for people who haven't seen it
i don't think i've ever seen it
can i just point out there's a lot of
comments saying bring out jordan like as
if we have him in a box that's not too
far from the truth yes
exactly we could probably get jordan
down here you think we could probably
we could we could ask
yeah or nuts we could ask jordan at the
end although he might not even be in yet
yeah i know that's true he can't seem
pretty yeah exactly it's 11. he knew he
gets it around bring out jordan exactly
jordan doesn't actually my lift my lyft
driver the other night was telling me
how much he loved george oh my god and
he and he also had a crush on sona oh so
good
was he a lift just on the lot
no he was a big big fan of the show he
was an intern yeah
uh but so people haven't watched uh i
haven't seen nutmeg before uh we're
gonna let's watch nut spoon and then we
will also kind of these guys will kind
of talk we'll kind of talk about it and
give a little bit of i love i'm about to
say this we're gonna give a little bit
of director's commentary oh jeez to the
stanley kubrickian masterpiece that is
nut spoon
let's do it
i've been doing this job for quite some
time
60 years and uh conan is the host of the
show i'd like to think i'm a pretty good
boss and uh
okay well i thought a good way to get
into this was with a complaint it's
important to me
that everyone here and that's
interesting
it starts with something completely
different just conan
it starts with the premise conan loves
his staff and cares about us here right
which is true
this morning and then put out the
complaint box
backstage and i thought it'd be funny if
like yeah just to kind of check
everything's full already after one day
there it is yeah that way if anyone has
a complaint they can just fill out a
card and i just like the idea that like
he mentions nut spoon a bunch of times
before you look at that these are from
one is that is that just because you
wanted to shove another joke in there
why not just have something to say hey
why not
[Music]
yeah i don't know i mean i i feel like
it's funnier if you're just sort of
slowly piling it on giving information
yeah
we need each note is about the nuts but
i think it's really really fun you're
kind of so basically you're you're
you're you're doing it kind of yeah so
the crowd's already heard the words nuts
like three times already and nobody
knows what it is right so you're kind of
building an anticipation for what it is
and it's just sounds fun yeah funny
words
what is it i don't know this is crazy
two words nut spoon oh yeah will kim
asks are the complaints in the box real
did you pull like a shining and make an
intern write a thousand nut spoon
comments i think bill and john rao just
wrote
is the bane of the entire crew's
existence
okay johnny that sounds a little extreme
i love that choice of making tony really
angry because it's kind of almost a b
story it keeps coming back and it adds
to it yeah right
more mystery now it's like why does tony
why is tony angry
like is there some history they have yes
there's a snack table backstage right
it's where the crew gets their snacks
and this is basically true sure yeah one
of the things on the snack table is what
dan buchanan asked what accent were you
going for sometimes is this with this uh
it's like almost new york staten island
yeah it's just like i grew up you know
i grew up in new jersey in new york city
so it's just kind of a little bit
different different kinds of nuts or
whatever each spectrum says that was the
best part you get really angry it is
funny how you can switch right back i
get it just tell me about the nut spoon
okay
okay so when the crew wants some nuts to
snack on we don't just grab them with
our hands because that spread
instead we use a spoon
to scoop up the nuts
and then we transfer the nuts from the
spoon so again
what i liked about this part is just do
you know what we call this spoon how
unnecessarily drawn out it is
right bingo you get a gold stuff
okay my favorite line right here
and so at this point you know the rest
of the writers and actors are out there
hoping that this is going well and
they're already on board so we're like
there's a big sigh of relief when you're
standing out on the floor in a wig
and you know there's like six pages left
right yeah when you're all you're in the
and they totally were even with the
long-winded parts they they were getting
it so it was a good crowd
[Applause]
todd levin on the left and levi
mcdougall other writers joining in chris
is nut spoon it's the skit that keeps on
giving that's true as it keeps on
packing and i i think one of the groups
yeah he gets to play with it too so it's
fun for conan the spoon is very small
and the bowl of the spoon i like the
show the closest there is like this is
all unnecessary
which is one of my favorite things to do
i think part of the thing though is like
you need the space like you need the
space to in to play around with the
absolute ridiculousness of the premise
yeah yeah okay i'm sorry tony is it
really that hard to pick up nothing is
good at callbacks to other sketches so
he's calling to me another character
robbie the high cameraman right this
character's been in a bunch any nuts
here at work
now here's my favorite part of the
sketch which is just a conversation
between the two of us which is not again
not necessary every time i got one nut
on the spoon
but then when i was trying to like
transfer that nut from the spoon to my
other hand
i dropped the nut
so all you're doing here is just
heightening how you're making a meal out
of something that's insanely tiny
i don't blame you i still eat nuts at
home though
yeah
that's pretty
guys i had no idea the nut spoon
situation was going on i really didn't
know everybody come on uh john's going
for the record
hey that's right master bill what record
are you talking about bill the nut spoon
record come on you don't want to miss
this all right so now we now we enter
into the third act of this sketch
so now it's like all right we actually
get to see the nut spoon in action right
we built it up again now no one's been
able to pick up more than two nuts with
the nut spoon john rao's going for three
go for it john what i love about this is
you you're now setting stakes right
you're not setting stakes here so
so here you go that's exactly what it
looks like
it's
yes nice john rapp from the props
department he works with tulle
he's great
pedro says plot twist for the sequel the
problem is actually the bowl not the
spoon he's right that's yeah
then we added a ton of extra nuts to the
table right i love that too
it's like two whole jars of nuts on the
table
wow
wow
tony you really opened my eyes to the
whole nut spoon situation now here's the
idea what if i replace the nut spoon
with this white plastic soup spoon okay
i don't see how that solves the problem
except
well it is slightly larger and a little
deeper than the current nut spoon oh
thanks conan we're gonna eat so many
nuts at the crew oscar party okay that's
great wait the oscars were sunday tony
shut up
and then right bring it the third time
right yeah everything's gonna bring
right there one more time
and i messed up those lines because i
forgot where the key cards were so i
just started i'm sorry
all hail the nut spoon everyone the
spoon
and then we get the chandelier and i
love that the crowd started laughing
along who was on the show that day who
was the first guest
things that involve a specific
logic that you can delve into twist
around over explain i think he has a
very mathematical mind i really think
that's interesting very loud so
right you set up you set up your own
you create your own internal logic and
if you stick to it right you can play
around in that and it's funny yeah you
create the rules then you then you play
by that right
uh well now we're going to have a big
fan of uh nut spoon uh join us here um
if he wants to come on over and take a
seat i'll i'll jump in the back here
as a request as requested as request
jordan
[Applause]
there you go thank you jordan
it is great to be here thank you you
were requested
now jordan you've actually brought uh
some nuts here should i actually do you
want me to give him my mic oh my alley
we got that okay great uh jordan you
brought some nuts now you are an
aficionado of pretty much everything
what did you think of the nut spoon
sketch well i feel like we're doing not
to disservice if we're talking about the
sketch and not talking about nuts
themselves and their health benefits
that's true now these came from my
office and i just want to make it
unscripted we didn't write this i didn't
write this i just want to make a
distinction we have two super foods here
we have almonds and the lesser known
pumpkin scenes i'm going to talk about
both of those things but first i want to
talk about almonds and the magnesium
content now magnesium is actually a
mineral that most americans are
currently deficient in believe it or not
in this age of supplements magnesium is
really hard to get from food the soil
has been depleted due to over farming
and organ meats have fallen out of favor
oregon meats used to be
primal yeah that's a that's an organ and
they're very rich in magnesium vitamin a
but unfortunately they're
out of the public taste
um supplementing with magnesium is not
an efficient way to get magnesium in the
body as well a lot of people use
transdermal magnesium when cavemen swam
in the ocean the ocean is rich with
magnesium and it absorbs through the
skin and the same way a nicotine patch
would absorb through the skin people
what does magnesium do for the magnesium
is a relaxant it's an anti-inflammatory
it uh helps you sleep it helps digestion
it relieves muscle cramps is this what
you wanted actually people are saying
he's actually right
i find this very interesting
anti-inflammatories is a good thing yeah
there's a little bit of uh controversy
regarding almonds as well you see a lot
of people like to have raw almonds in
their natural state but unfortunately a
few years ago in california there was a
salmonella outbreak in raw almonds due
to some
unscrupulous production techniques and
as a result the overreaction was the
state of california opposed the law that
almonds that come out of california must
be pasteurized and they're no longer raw
these are
the spoon these are organic and steam
pasteurized now you can still get
unpasteurized raw almonds just not the
ones from california unfortunately a
very high percentage of u.s almonds do
come out of california a lot of people
buy italian almonds for that reason and
then quickly i wanted to go into pumpkin
seeds which is the greatest vegetarian
source of zinc now zinc is another very
important mineral for male testosterone
virility libido immunity
and immunity
yeah and zinc is another mineral where a
lot of people are deficient now of
course oysters the richest source of
zinc and they've been known as an
aphrodisiac for many centuries in fact
in all uh different cultures around the
world but those are really good um this
is a nice
herbs in them too
yeah this particular one i'm not a big
fan of raw pumpkin seeds uh i find them
a little boring but these particular
ones are roasted this brand is super
seeds
and uh they're non-gmo
uh yet not organic but um yeah so these
were in my office and uh just want to
talk about the fiber content and nuts
where did you get those
uh i believe both of these were
purchased from whole foods
wow
um
yeah fiber is another deficient part of
the american diet you know fiber is a
large part of digestion and it's amazing
when i go to some
more rural areas of the country the
meals that are served don't contain any
fiber in any form whatsoever whether it
be vegetables or nuts so i encourage
people to eat nuts for those reasons
wow well jordan thank you
and what did you think of the nut spoon
sketch i thought the nut spoon sketch
was great it actually uh a couple of us
in the office um that sketch inspired
memories of a much older sketch from
back in late night in new york um
may have even predated youtube yeah it
was called um
the uh the be yourself gang or the
do-it-yourself gang i think it was
written by a guy named tommy blatcha oh
wow yeah
but um
yeah it was a really uh irreverent
sketch that um kind of took all these
twists and turns and and left you
thinking what what did i just see and
when we saw it you know that's why you
guys may have covered this i hadn't
watched what you guys done and i guess
it took a couple of days between the
first time we rehearsed it and finally
aired a couple of tweaks and um
i was afraid because sometimes when
something you know gets uh delayed you
you hope that it gets on air and yeah at
all and i so wanted that sketch to get
on air so i'm glad it did work out
favorably in the end yeah yeah
wow well george schlansky everybody
thank
you at that a little drop in little
knowledge there from jordan i had no
idea but i didn't know that about zinc
or magnesium
man look at this it's educational uh and
all man people are
oh my god people are people love jordan
oh my gosh
he's a legend he's a light jordan is a
legend that's true a living legend a
monkey
a giant a giant who walks in
a giant who walks who walks among us
well and actually jordan brought up a a
good point which is so
nuts was written a while before it got
on the air a couple weeks i would say
probably two weeks yeah which for i mean
in our world is a long time right
because usually we're writing stuff the
day before or the day of so what's the
process of you come up with an idea then
do you go to a writer's meeting and
pitch the idea or do you just write out
the idea
how does that work what's differently
all the time i mean sometimes you can
[Music]
write it up after like that sounds funny
and
sometimes there's back and forth other
times the timing is so tight that
there's not that many notes and you just
you just go on and rehearse it the way
it is that's crazy that's why i was so
surprised so surprised that there were
no changes
or cuts to the sketch in between the
first time we rehearsed it and when it
aired because i think the longness of it
and the detail of it is part of its
strength like you you do the whole thing
or you you don't do it yeah i guess
conor reckons can't shorten
or tony the cameraman's speech up front
without
it being the same sketch he needs to go
into that level of detail
so when you take uh
when you take a sketch that you really
like to rehearsal
what's that like
terrifying i remember i remember looking
at michael gordon who's been here since
1993. yeah he was on the original staff
actually yeah he plays the masturbating
bear right yeah he's the only writer
who's been here since day one since day
one right but i remember when i was like
in my
i don't know second or third year and
i'm at rehearsal and i'm looking at his
face when he had a sketch on and he's
like
yeah
and i was like wow that feeling
never goes away because you just you
it's total exposure you've brought it
down and this is your baby it's your
baby and it's either gonna fly or it's
gonna just die yeah and i've always said
this we don't really have rehearsals we
have auditions yeah that's how i feel
it's kind of like
it's very sink or swim it's very binary
yeah i think because they're like what
do we got we have this much room show me
what you got right and it's like yes
yes yes and that's it yeah and what's it
terrifying is there a big difference
between something that's done mostly
live like nut spoon and for instance
something
uh dan you did which was rub light which
was amazing and that's my all-time
favorite and uh
and much more of kind of a a
pre-pre-taped kind of commercial bit the
the advantage of the pre-tape thing is
that you have all the bells and whistles
you can make it look differently you can
edit the comedy specifically so a
pre-taped thing you're kind of
it's a little more protected but by the
same token if it's not working it's just
dead air people are looking up something
live
live sketches have this energy that i
think comforts conan and andy and
involves them in a way that they're kind
of like oh this is fun you know conan
gets to talk to tony so there's an
advantage when you're you're mounting a
live sketch that i think conan and andy
i just want to point out
a fat guy has amazing legs
javier i'm assuming i'm fat guy thank
you very
exactly much more proud of my guns they
like your tattoo too they were like they
liked your tattoos oh yeah you're saying
yeah
i remember that when we brought the the
rublight commercial down
the editor rob ash on that like i told
him what i wanted and he
so far succeeded right
he made it so much better the way he
made it look and the way he timed each
time the song came back and the song was
directed
what's the premise of rub light for
people who haven't well i was up late at
night one night at home and i was just
the all those late night commercials
have the same tone like you can do this
with that and you can even do that with
that and you can do this with it and i
was wondering what that would be like if
the benefit wasn't obvious right if it
was a product
where the main feature of it was never
quite explained right so it's just a
light that you can rub against things
yeah
why do you rub it right and it had a
song you can rub it on a bit but
it's just something that keeps on coming
back and
so i'm very proud i'm very proud i got
to sing that and you're good
but rob did such a good job and just
conan had a cold that day and i just
remember him watching it rehearsal he
was going
like he was laughing so hard he was
talking
and i was like i knew it was funny but i
didn't think it was going to be that
well received and then that was just
didn't they make it else didn't they
make our house cough up blood yeah yeah
yeah
and it's interesting like talking about
you know you know kind of rehearsal
being almost like an audition and
talking about kind of conan's mood you
know we do this thing on teamcoco.com
called scraps where so much great stuff
comes out of our rehearsal that's just
off the cuff and it's fun to watch conan
in his mood and so nut spoon took a
couple times before it kind of got on
the air and uh so the day that kind of
nuts the day that nuts been got on the
air uh we have a great scrap that we're
about to show you guys of conan
and you so you can see the tone at which
nut spoon uh uh was shown in rehearsal
and i think conor was in a great mood
and and definitely i think it's one of
the one of the reasons why it got you on
that day was he i think he was well you
know what you can decide for yourself
here's a scrap never before seen scrap
from rehearsal uh of nut spoon enjoy
stick around for the colonoscopy
exactly
aaron blair on base right i think we
gotta do nut spoon i don't think i think
if we don't do nut spoon now
right
i mean isn't nut spoon what we're all
about
is it nut spoon
steve holland are trying to leave their
earplugs
and our interns get to watch rehearsal
andy's tweeting at representative james
inhale
somebody pull me a clip of that so i can
send it to those kids parents
andy by the way has some of the best
one-liners
well that's his secret power that's that
spoon
whatever
oh my god before photoshop scrap was
awesomely hilarious
that's great that was an angler andrew
weinberg
what is he saying he's always looking at
his father being there for my
colonoscopy tomorrow at six why do i
have to be there
you don't have to i thought you said i
had to be there no no i is this i've
seen it pal you're giving him
i'm not kidding it's the only time i've
ever been happy is when yeah
you were penetrated and drugged no i
didn't feel that at all it's that drug
they give you well if they're just
talking about traits
i don't care about that part
all he's concerned about is minutes and
times
[Music]
hi i'm conan o'brien if you thought this
sketch could have gone longer let us
know
so obviously everyone already thinks are
you nervous at this point are you
nervous that he's like ripping on the
sketch before you seen it
this is
after we've already worked out a couple
times he knows what the sketch is
longer suggestions that's why the crowd
is dying to hear from you
why not
that's great we could have done that
that was not a bad idea yeah exactly
what conan just suggested oh yeah if you
thought this sketch could have gone
online right exactly yeah
it's always interesting like ending a
sketch uh speaking of ending things guys
i think that's gonna do it uh jordan you
wanna come back and say goodbye to
everyone people love you people people
people are really just here for the
jordan schlansky i learned so much about
exactly yeah we
all learned a lot from jordan as always
jordan what brand t-shirt are you
wearing right now that's a smartphone
this is james purse yeah james gross
probably eleven hundred dollars right
yeah no that's very nice material yeah
how much do you think that you're gonna
ask how much do you think that t-shirt
cost oh boy this one was probably sixty
dollars i think that's too much for a
t-shirt
but i mean
this is from uh new york city burger
joint remember the place called burger
oh yeah yeah parker burger joint uh the
secret's out now i'm sure because of the
internet but it's a hidden burger place
in the park meridian hotel midtown
manhattan in midtown manhattan delicious
how hidden is it it can't be that hidden
it's kind of behind curtains you go into
the lobby of the hotel and then you look
around you're like i guess i have the
wrong hotel you definitely okay kind of
nowhere the only indication that it's
there in fact is a neon sign of that
exact logo yeah you have to know to look
for it but now i think it's just so
highly publicized
um guys thank you for joining us this
has been uh the stream coco uh
especially stream coco nut spoon
spectacular thanks
thank you
jacob miller
that was great and telling us about nuts
uh thank you guys you can watch nut
spoon as well as rub light and all the
other great sketches
along with a bunch of remotes uh
starring mr jordan schlansky
teamcoco.com
comedy we will see you guys next time
see you later bye
thanks